Black Mirror's fourth season hasn't even aired
yet, but fans are already starting to parse
out Easter eggs from the preview.
And if it's anything like the seasons before
it, the new season should be filled with them.
But before we get to the new season, let's
take a look back at some of the most interesting
references Black Mirror has made so far.
The Waldo Moment
Black Mirror Easter eggs first started appearing
in Season 2's "The Waldo Moment," the story
of a failed comedian whose character becomes
the face of global movement after a talk show
outburst.
The episode harks back to the very first Black
Mirror installment, "The National Anthem,"
which was infamous for the scene in which
British Prime Minister Michael Callow has,
um, intimate relations with a pig on live
television in order to save the life of a
kidnapped royal.
Naturally, both episodes feature a lot of
news reports, and "The Waldo Moment" marked
the first time fictional network UKN reappeared
— the channel that beamed Pig-gate across
the nation and around the world.
Look a little closer, and you'll notice both
episodes also feature the same news bulletin
declaring that an unrelated character has
been "cleared of wrongdoing following paparazzi
scuffle."
"The Waldo Moment" also contains an Easter
egg linking it with "Fifteen Million Merits,"
which featured characters trying to escape
the life of an energy production drone by
winning a talent competition.
In that episode, contestant Abi Khan failed
to impress the judges with her vocals, but
they did envision a future for in the adult
film industry.
"So to be a singer, you gotta be truly exceptional."
"Yeah."
As a wink to that development, in "The Waldo
Moment," a digital billboard shot of her can
be seen next to an image of Waldo.
White Christmas
A few months before Mad Men's final episodes
aired, actor Jon Hamm decided to hop from
the '60s business world into the dystopian
future by way of Black Mirror's holiday episode,
"White Christmas."
In the episode, he plays a man with a much
more sordid past than Dick Whitman who's cooperating
with police on another case to get his own
criminal sentence reduced.
As he makes acquaintances with another character,
we get some smalltalk containing a wink to
his star-making role.
"My job was completely different.
You'll never guess what that was."
"Marketing?"
And that wasn't the only interesting reference
of the episode.
The other character flips past an advertisement
for the "Fifteen Million Merits" program Hot
Shots, and there's a karaoke scene that features
the same song that Abi performed in the talent
show.
Meanwhile, one of Hamm's online cohorts goes
by the screen name Pie Ape, which was that
episode's slang for a fat person — and another
is named Waldo.
Meanwhile, fictional news network UKN makes
another comeback in the episode, this time
to inform viewers that the court has rejected
an appeal of Victoria Skillane.
You might remember her as the woman from Season
2's "White Bear" who has her memory wiped
nightly and is forced to relive a single day
of torment indefinitely as punishment for
her part in the demise of a child.
"White Christmas" might have seemed like a
Santa-friendly episode, but the showrunners
were clearly working with the Easter bunny
to make all these references.
Nosedive
Another nod to the disgraced Prime Minister
arrives in Season 3's premiere episode "Nosedive."
The episode is a satire about a social media
climber who's terribly obsessed with the popularity
of an old friend.
As she checks her profile, we see a status
update from Michael Callow pop up, which reveals
that he's "just gotten thrown out of the zoo
again."
Looks like they don't trust him around livestock
anymore.
Later, when Lacie is forced to ride a bus
with fans of a show called Sea of Tranquility,
it's also a reminder of the inaugural episode,
because one of the show's special effects
designers was hired by Callow's team to try
and come up with a digital swine solution.
Playtest
Season 3's "Playtest" centers on an American
backpacker who takes part in a test run of
a new virtual reality horror game at a site
just outside of London.
Cooper is given the inside track on the gaming
company by British hook-up Sonja, who's played
by an actress from "Fifteen Million Merits."
Later, the same symbol that appears on the
mask of the armed hunter throughout "White
Bear" can be seen on one of the discs that
later turn to gopher holes as part of the
whack-a-mole style warm-up game.
Sonja also shows him a copy of EDGE magazine
with the gaming company's founder, Shou Saito,
on the cover.
Easter egg hunters were quick to point out
the block of text located in the bottom corner
of the page that advertises an article about
Granular, the company behind the AI bees that
run amok in the Season 3 finale, "Hated in
the Nation."
Meanwhile, the words at the top of the page
refer to the virtual consciousness company
TCKR.
Shut Up and Dance
Season 3's "Shut Up and Dance" followed the
plight of Kenny, who's coerced into committing
various crimes by hackers who are blackmailing
him.
While he's being threatened by text, you can
clearly see a sticker of our cartoon friend
Waldo lurking on his desk.
And when another target of the hackers opens
a webpage to a story about her leaked private
emails, you can see several callbacks to prior
episodes on-screen.
First, there's the shamed former Prime Minister
from the series premiere in the side column,
announcing his divorce.
And just below him is a courtroom sketch of
Victoria Skillane from Season 2.
Above that, there's also an ad for "One Smart
Cookie" and the "kitchen tech of tomorrow,"
is a clear callback to the "White Christmas"
special where computer-generated versions
of people are created to serve their host's
every need.
And above that there's a mention of the talent
competition from "15 Million Merits."
Last but not least, there's also a familiar
bank logo in the episode.
The bank Kenny robs appears to be a branch
of the same company that failed to dispense
Cooper's flight money in "Playtest."
Perhaps more interestingly, the logo also
greatly resembles the one that appears on
the military uniforms and equipment in "Men
Against Fire," which is a pretty deep piece
of commentary on the profitability of war.
Hated in the Nation
During the episode "Hated in the Nation,"
policewoman Karin Parke watches a UKN news
report, and along the bottom of the screen
runs a headline announcing the US military's
approval of the MASS Project, the implants
that allow the soldiers to take out targets
in cold blood in "Men Against Fire".
It also tells us that cookies have finally
been given human rights protections, which
is welcome news after everything that went
down in "White Christmas."
Meanwhile, the story centers on a madman's
plot to use artificially intelligent pollination
bees to assassinate people of the public's
hashtag choosing — and who else do they
want eliminated but Michael Callow himself.
Meanwhile, some people are pleading for Victoria
Skillane's freedom, while others want her
in the ground.
Interestingly, it turns out Karen's new partner
Blue Coulson was instrumental in taking down
Skillane's boyfriend, Ian Rannoch.
The news also mentions that the gaming company
from "Playtest" is revealed to be under investigation
over the disappearance of a tourist.
That's a clear reference to our poor pal Cooper.
And Victoria Skillane has attempted her end
her own life after continuing to be incarcerated
at White Bear.
Yikes.
Here's hoping Season 4 is as loaded with callbacks
as what we've seen so far!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!